so I'm gonna bury you right here but
you'll be dead before Steve he pulls
your teeth accurate he says all right
take his teeth out back in those days
they didn't have DNA they would identify
bodies by dental records my name is Mark
Silverman and I was involved in
organized crime hello my name is John
panisi I'm a former made member of the
Lucchesi crime family my name is Lee
Thompson I'm a pickpocket for Hoya my
name is Brian Stanton I'm a casino
executive in Las Vegas my name is
Charlie santori
Kane Vincent Dyer
today we're going to be looking at
casino Heist movie scenes Mafia scenes
safe cracking auth Heist Clips Irish mob
movie scenes bank robbery scenes
pickpocketed in movies I'm gonna judge
just how real they are
[Music]
on the Chicago Loop I would actually see
lots of businessmen reading newspapers
and this steel is spot on the
interaction the amount of eye contact
it's not too much it doesn't knock him
over it's a little whoops the guy is
shielding his his own pocket with his
newspaper that he's reading he's already
done the pickpocketing work for the
pickpocket unknowingly the technique is
beautiful and we're watching it from a
spectator sport point of view
it's not tried to move away because he's
there's no heat on him but he will get
out of that Carriage when I went with
the police we often tell people about a
thing called looping where you might
think I know that person but you don't
but you've subconsciously you've seen
them a couple of times in a short space
of time because they're not getting
anywhere but they've got an agenda the
London Underground is notorious for
pickpockets because it's crowded it's
been reported that there's in one
station alone it was 139 cases I've
picked pocketing close your bag keep it
in front of you especially on a crowded
tube or Metro it's a 10. the technique
is beautiful
and unfortunately does happen
as he raises his arm he's actually
raising his pocket to her hand so she
and has to stand like that and clip
whatever she needs to clip and then when
he puts his arm down the pocket moves
away from the item and
his peripheral vision
her head is to his right side he can't
see anything over this right side now
I'm not telling you this so you go out
and do it I'm telling you this so you
don't be a victim of it the greater
movements supersedes that are the Lesser
movement or the greater force supersedes
that of a left that's a force so they
say if I tap your leg with a pencil and
then hit your shoulder with a hammer
you'll forget me tapping the pencil leg
but you'll feel the hammer so
misdirection and slight hand is super
important and you can easily do that
we've got a piece of paper or an
envelope
it's not a bulky item so it's not
perfect I would give it an eight
[Applause]
oh
I love it I love it I think this movie
Super well choreographed
pressure
in gripping that purse or that wallet
with the Chopsticks you're gonna have to
be pretty spectacular gripping most
people kind of can pick up sushi so a
heavy purse with coins in maybe we don't
know what's in there
um
would be trickier but it can be done
I've done things like this on behalf of
the police
to draw attention as a crime prevention
but just to show people how easy it was
and how vulnerable they are
yeah 100
could
um because he's moving and she's moving
he's not static so the movement is
covering all her movement definitely
she's taken that leather strap watch
with that technique because if you look
the crystal is really heavy so when you
undo
the tongue bit through the prongs the
weight of the crystal will make the wall
the watch fall away from the wrist
so and what's actually happened is he's
actually moving away from the watch the
friction could make him go what's going
on so he's actually aiding it himself
unknowingly and the weight of that
Crystal would make it fall away easier
for her it's not how quick can you do it
it's when you do it so she's not
actually looking at the wrist she's
looking into his eyes
and she's constantly looking into his
eyes she never once looks at his wrist
when she's doing the watch steal you
might think there's a lot going on that
would never happen but you're looking
from a bird's eye view but they're all
communicating with telephones on the
earpieces and with visual signals people
at Street parties who have been drinking
are easy targets because one the
inhibitions have gone and that makes the
element of surprise better for the
pickpocket to get close to you my
colleague Apollo Robbins I could see in
the clips because I can tell his body
language and I know what he looks like
was involved in this it's phenomenal I'd
give it 10 out of 10.
doing here
chances of her having anything in that
pocket it's highly unlikely because it's
quite it's quite a smart trouser suit
and the pockets high and although for
the girl in the clip being small down is
really advantageous to be in a
pickpocket because you're low down to
people's bags and Pockets but the Black
Canary is quite a tall lady compared to
her so she's got to reach up into the
pocket and
just the timing is wrong 100 she would
catch her
could be that the the three finger dip
if you like it doesn't matter they don't
three fingers a whole hand she's a child
who's got a small hands
I hate that bit I hate it clearly just
done for the movie Zero technique to do
a bracelet
how do you know what clasp is on the
bracelet there are so many different
sorts does it come over the hands if
it's over the hand there's one important
thing that gets in the way that's the
thumb she just takes it off
but her hand is on the bench so she's
got to go under to find the clasp and it
clearly undoes from underneath fake
it's a normal thing that you would be
used to seeing someone's broken their
arm or they've got it in a sling or
people carry babies in front of them
that are not babies that's a a doll you
can buy realistic babies I've actually
witnessed and seen the babies and I do
the baby trick myself everything is
doable so I would give this out of ten
and eight hello my name is John panisi
I'm a former made member of the Lucchesi
crime family I also got involved as a
low associate to the Gambino family when
I was very young today we're going to be
looking at Mafia scenes and movies and
TV
and what's depicted here is a guy
getting what we would call straightened
out
inducted and it's inaccurate by the way
that they're kidding around this is a
serious ceremony where there's no joking
or playing around
okay
at Saint Peter my family's Saint now was
that Cod burn so may your soul burn in
hell if you betray your friends in the
family there was two members being made
and that is not accurate it would be one
at a time they would bring one person up
into the room and do the ceremony and
then call the other one up some of the
things were accurate that was said and
obviously the pricking of the finger and
the burning of the saint but all in all
it wasn't
a hundred percent
I don't know if they put it there for
this reason but a lot of times are
superstitious about birds they don't
even give cards out with Birds on it
they don't think it's a good sign
they're doing really good this year with
the Sportsman yeah it's been good I'm
gonna give it to you my boy it's yours
nothing set in stone
of how how long you have to go as an
associate before you become an inductive
member some people have been Associates
for 10 15 years five years 10 years
three years when I first got
straightened out it was the at that time
the highest honor to be inducted into a
family and to become a wise guy and to
be treated with that respect looking
back on it now it was the lowest point
of my life it was an embarrassment
because basically everything that I
thought the life was about
was a Foss from a scale from 1 to 10 I'd
rate it at three
friends
passing around jewelry and that's insane
I don't even I couldn't even answer what
that is about and why they would put
something like that we want to do
business with you Michael
this was a commission meeting with the
heads of families
New York is chopped up by the five
families and everybody knows their place
and they know who's who
commission would meet if there was
business to discuss within the families
and decisions to be made only the people
involved in the meeting would obviously
be in the know of where and when and
what time they were meeting they could
take uh and on the boss a consulate or
even a captain if they want the
different families intermingle a lot
more than people understand and it's not
so territorial as people think
if they were attempting to hit somebody
it would definitely not be that flashy
it was very Hollywood to me with the
helicopter and the Machine Guns this
would never happen it would be very
low-key and be done quietly
on a scale of one to ten I would rate
this as zero
and my name is Charlie santori I'm the
owner of santorian sunlock and safe I'm
a safe technician meaning safe cracker
in Southern California today we're going
to look at some clips on safe cracking
and films
the clicking dial that Hollywood loves
so much they typically have a bearing
surface on it it's usually very very
smooth if it was properly installed it
shouldn't be clicking there's like one
or two models of a junkie safe that you
can get at Staples where the dial clicks
it's not really a real thing
[Music]
the sort of dialing sequence that she
would be doing in order to do so is not
how she's dialing here she's actually
working
backwards to to how we typically would
the principle of it is that wheels are
being searched for low spots and what
that involves is parking certain wheels
and moving other wheels and there's a
certain repetitive sequence to to doing
that by people that know how to do this
and she's not doing this here
you can do this
there's a difference between people
burglarizing things and people opening
things the the way that we open them to
put them back in service they're not
going to be sitting around trying to
manipulate a safe open they would drill
it open even opening a safe like this
even if you're drilling it it's also
extremely difficult you're not
haphazardly drilling holes in something
you're not vandalizing something when we
open safes the idea is it's like
arthroscopic surgery we're doing it in a
minimally invasive way the whole thing
is a very academic study
we're supposed to believe when that
click happened that final click is the
fence of the lock dropping but here with
Vault locks and safe locks you have to
do a final turn to pull the lock bolt
back so there's a certain amount of
travel that then opens that lock so she
dials the combination
here she stops at 50 the fence drops she
sang the safe is open and he turns the
handle but the safe wouldn't be open
even if the lock was unlocked because
she didn't retract the lock bolt you
know this notion of somebody creeping
around and manipulating a safe open it
does happen and it has happened but nine
times out of ten it's Sledge Hammers and
wedges or Grinders or saws cutting the
thing open so I want to be generous it's
three
thank you
he's taking the fingerprint off the door
with tape could have been the cleaning
ladies print that he pulled off of there
this actually broke my head a little bit
if you pull the print off with tape and
you turn it over and put a ring on it
and put Loctite in it aren't you
actually making it a cast of the inverse
of the fingerprint his safe is serious
how serious we talking Scotty
the Carbondale Carbondale is a made-up
name but the vault door itself I looked
through hundreds and hundreds of photos
of Vault doors and I'm pretty certain
that the art directors base this off of
a very early Debold vault door
foreign
this is a strong arm mini rig that's
used for putting pressure when one's
drilling so that aspect of it is
definitely accurate
we'll go do a quick job it winds up
being something where you don't have
your full tool kit with you so I mean
there's lots of times when we've been
running around trying to bend wires and
make tools and sort of have to come up
with something that we didn't have with
us
[Music]
supposedly he's freezing it and it's
going to expand and crack this door
apart what they showed us was the bolt
work inside of the safe and the door pan
there's a big door pan if you poured a
gallon of water in there it would spill
out the bottom of the door pan basically
if by chance he froze it and the ice
expanded I mean obviously water can
expand glaciers expand over time the
thing about a vault door is in this case
there's a thin back panel that's like
sheet metal essentially on the back of
the door so then the idea that that's
going to expand is Pure Fantasy it would
blow the back panel off before it blew
the door off
there's nothing here what'd you say
it's a soup I opened up a couple of
safes that were at a Blockbuster Video a
while and there was Astroglide condoms
and some dirty photos so I don't know if
a manager was having a fling with
somebody but that was pretty unexpected
on the more valuable side of things we
once opened a safe in an affluent part
of Beverly Hills that people had
recently moved into a home the former
owner was gone there were Bulgari
necklaces Cartier necklaces krugerrands
Gia certificates I mean I I can only
imagine that it must have been you know
mid to high six-figure lick but I think
that people get traumatized when there's
that much left because they're not
expecting to have a moral conflict sort
of you know it's technically mine but
this obviously meant a great deal to
whoever it was that was living here
before it's nonsense but the mini rig is
real so I'm gonna give it a three
there's certainly a lot of safes that
are known among people who do this kind
of work that are very very difficult to
open very well guarded locks so yeah
there is some truth to that but if the
world's living locksmith do I represent
your greatest chance of opening it I can
with humility
say yes the biggest myth I think is that
there's some boffin or there there's
some Maven who has the you know Magic
Touch to get the thing open the
forelocks
you know what it is
no no of course not
it's a rotating randomization mechanism
if you mess it up again it locks forever
forever Las Vegas is overrun with
zombies the idea that they're gonna
bring some genius to come and manipulate
open four locks on a vault or as is
ridiculous they would just bring a
coring crew they'd bring coring stuff
and they'd bore a hole in the side of
the Vault and get it open how long
we'll take you to a minute
30 minutes the idea that somebody would
manipulate open four Vault locks in half
an hour is Pure Fantasy
he's supposedly manipulating this open
he's not even looking at the dial which
is where he would be looking for in the
indications that he would use to
manipulate it open and there's also some
hieroglyphs or some scrawling that he
wrote on or he drew on the front of the
door that really has nothing to do with
what he would be doing in order to get
this open
[Music]
the doors are always heavy you're
talking about a multi-multi-ton door
there are compression systems that that
have spinning wheels not all Vault doors
have though some have handles
according to him this Vault has four
locks on it when the vault door swings
open we see that there's actually only
two Vault locks on the back of the door
and a time lock with five movements I've
never seen a five movement time lock I'm
going to give it a two as far as the
realism goes my name is Mark Silverman
and I was involved in organized crime
with the Italians and uh the Irish today
we're going to be looking at some Irish
mob movie scenes what do you get your
period
stop
so you have a good idea if the strangers
in there or if there's something that
doesn't look right you can really find
out if somebody's there to infiltrate
the bar or cause trouble
[Music]
that's a great scene I I could tell you
one thing and and it struck me right
away when I saw the movie for the first
time the state police are not going to
try to put one of their own inside of a
crew especially a dangerous crew that's
why they recruit informants or top
batchelon informants because
the informants can walk the walk and
talk the talk and
I have never really seen
an undercover police officer inside of a
crew a lot of people used to say well
you know I know that guy's a cop because
of his shoes I would say
you don't think that they know what
shoes to wear and what not to wear you
know yeah always always looking over
your shoulder for that yeah you know I
saw a club when I came in here
when I was pulling into the parking lot
I didn't miss that but these days I
don't have to worry about it well guys
on the street like me that are looking
at us saying wow that's pretty good
[Music]
thank you schools have
thank you Frank
police corruption back in
the 80s and the 90s was rampant Whitey
Bulger certainly wasn't the only guy
that had the inside track with some of
the Departments whether they be local or
state or federal
other guys I mean you're not going to
survive on the street if you don't have
friends within law enforcement and back
then
you know police didn't really make as
much money as they did today and they
were much more easily corrupted as we
moved on to the 2000s I think that uh
they got a little more
stringent you know they wanted to
eradicate organized crime they wanted to
just put that final nail in the coffin
which they claim to have done several
times we're not even supposed to be
doing this this close to the Worcester
the side of Western
is that so it says him says Costello
This is very accurate so they're
obviously nervous it's all about
territory if you're dealing drugs doing
any type of business in somebody else's
territory you are absolutely open to
discipline however that discipline is
carried out it depends on the severity
of the action like if you look at
like Medford you know Somerville you
know Winter Hill South Boston you know
who's who and you know we should be
doing things and where you shouldn't
because if you don't someone will get
your attention one way or another and
you probably won't like it but
that's what happens you know he's got
some real good scenes in there and uh
good storyline so yeah I'd say it's
pretty accurate I give it a I give it a
seven
listen uh just wanted to stop by and
tell you myself
is that the zip code for South Boston uh
no it's Charleston everybody has the the
Fighting Irish guy usually like on the
on their calf you know what I mean and
you know it's it's not really like a a
requirement or anything it's just that
they're proud I mean and they should be
the they're always going to honor and
respect it where they come from
I think my guys can handle it without me
I mean I wouldn't hire them without you
and I wouldn't hire you without them
you're a unit
everybody in a crew has a role part of
his crew is the bank robbery crew he's
not going to put your flip head on it
you know he's not going to do that he's
not going to hire one without the other
they're going to do it together they do
it right they do it well they keep the
money flowing the Irish mafia I mean
they're they're Loosely knit
Cruise you know that don't necessarily
follow the uh the Pyramid of the
structure of power that the Italians
have you have your bookies you have your
drug dealers you have your hijackers
everybody has a role but the earner the
guy that fill in the pockets of the
higher ups is the most important guy in
that crew just out of respect smooth
things over
take this Farm all right
not going to cut us
you're going to do what I ask yeah what
I want is money you know he's much more
valuable to him continuing to make money
you know your earners
you put you will do anything to keep
them earning for you because they're
hard to find believe me when I tell you
you know there's a lot of Knuckleheads
out there that uh you put them on the
street you know they last about a week
it's like in reality too it's the
old-timers that really have the juice I
always respected the old time is more
than anything because these guys have
more wisdom in their pinky finger than
the guys the young that's a nine
just like that I always want to
hell so a lot of people believe that
Whitey Bulger was part of the Winter
Hill Gang he was at the beginning I
don't think I would ever say he was the
leader of the winter Hood gang he was
the leader of the Bulger group all right
whatever you want to call it he was
running with the gangs in South Boston
there was a power struggle and they
wanted to iron out those problems and
the ultimate result of it was hey let's
combine it you know why don't we make
ourselves strong why don't we blend
salty and went to Hill and make it all
one crew and that's what they did but in
1978 all of a sudden this huge
indictment comes down against the entire
winterhill gang I mean guys like Whitey
stevies Howie John laterano The Who's
Who of the Irish mafia in 1978 and it's
funny because as it was taking its
course you know these guys either went
on the limb or some of them went to jail
or were awaiting trial
all of a sudden you hear the word
unindicted co-conspirators when it came
to Steve flemmy and Whitey Bulger so
when unindicted co-conspirator kind of
raised a lot of antennas and again
that's where people fail to realize is
that
once he eliminates Winter Hill
he becomes the Bulger group I told him
everything the IRA childhood the whole
bit this will be dead before Stephen
pulls your teeth accurate
accurate he says to Stevie flummy he
says all right take his teeth out you
know back in those days they didn't have
DNA
you know so they would identify bodies
by dental records I think uh in the
movie too they they refer to um
a Dumping Ground where they dumped a lot
of bodies yeah quite a few I remember
when the state police were digging it up
it was bad it was really bad I thought
that was great everything down from the
you know to the walk to the eyes you
know why he had these eyes that uh
like grayish blue with like no emotion
behind them and uh I think you'll see a
lot of times in this movie when they
show the eyes like they'll Focus
specifically on the eyes
they looked pretty good I'm giving this
one an eight I thought this one was
gritty it was raw it was pretty accurate
hi I'm Kane Vincent Dyer I committed
over a hundred bank robberies and a
period of almost two years so after
turning myself in I decided to form a
coaching company that helps people
transform their lives and today we are
going to be judging the authenticity of
bank robbery scenes
he has on this helmet so he doesn't need
a mask he doesn't look like he'd be
coming in a Rob necessarily it looks
like he just kept his helmet on which
guys do all the time
I can really really relate to this him
wearing that backpack I would sometimes
either wear a backpack or a duffel bag
strapped around the front and you can
still have the control of your hands
it's the only drawback if you get any
kind of tracker or die pack and you walk
off and that die pack explodes he's
wearing it on his chest
so real it typically happens your first
time or two bank robbery is bad enough
so
with that out there then what we know
from watching the movie is he's in a
really desperate situation sometimes the
desperation kind of overrides the moral
compass it's very accurate it takes a
second for him to pump himself up
he doesn't want those gloves coming off
you know so obviously he's really
conscious of not leaving any type of
fingerprint also
it's holding his sleeve to the jacket
down which could be covering up some
type of uh tattoo interesting that he
picked a bank with glass because of the
glass he's got to throw it over to them
and you know they could put any kind of
device in that bag it almost shows most
more so the desperation
that he went into this bank that is
secure with glass and everything like
that but he was still so desperate that
it didn't stop him
him having a problem with his motorcycle
is
sure it's happened
they just blow through that red light
with all those cars coming I don't think
uh
the intelligent police officer would do
that just because you're putting a lot
more people at risk I would actually
rate this a nine going into the bank
leading up to the bank preparing getting
nervous everything he did even the
mistakes he made inside
were actual mistakes that if you you
know you haven't done it you would
probably make
this book that looks like no one could
ever get in except for probably the U.S
military we have to keep in mind
that this movie everything about this
movie is supposed to be over the top yes
they do have very intricate lock safes
and things like that time block safes
things that are really hard to get into
but a lot of time during business hours
they will keep
certain safes open just so the employees
can have access I learned everything so
every bank I went into
I knew whether it was going to have a
safe such as the one that's in this
scene or if it was going to be a regular
open doors and if it were like this I
would pass unless
I found in one of their manuals or knew
that they would keep this door open
between certain times
could I get it
then where things were more manual
oh yeah I I mean it it would have taken
a considerable amount of time to break
into that that's not like a three or
four minute deal
foreign
a weapon in there like that unless you
have a security guard that was armed you
got to keep in mind if you shoot that
shotgun and he hits that bank robbery
suspect those rounds are probably
exiting the perpetrator and going
straight into the bank customer or the
bank employee
that school bus doesn't have any damage
on it and he just crashed through
a cemented Stone building
and if you remember it had to go up the
steps because when they were off the
building they went up the steps so that
like a totally Hollywood right
definitely a one
they know exactly what they're doing you
can tell by the way they move where they
go they know the layout of this place
bank robberies that are done by a lot of
different gangs
this is how they go in and this is how
they operate just with brute force and
sheer
fearful nine o'clock I don't know why do
I say 15. he asked her
uh something very specific about the
bank which he already knew I would ask a
bank employee a question
just because
I knew the answer and I wanted to see if
they were going to be straight with me
or not I wanted to see if they were
going to be nervous how they were going
to respond to the question I was asking
we just wanted to see if she was going
to cooperate
hold it
finally around this address you pull the
alarm no no a lot of people believe that
everyone in a bank you know all
employees have silent alarms that's not
accurate there's there's specific people
that have the silent alarmed that are
allowed to push it
bleaching is something
seen done before I
doing it to get rid of all type of
evidence you know once you put bleach on
anything
everything just kind of dissipates it's
just interesting to me that they're
doing that like the gloves they they
have on so much that covers them up I
would say this movie is a 10. for the
realistic way that these guys are just
that aggressive unfortunately you have a
lot of guys that go in and that's how
they do it
foreign
this scene here is very high tech this
isn't a normal bank robbery right there
are guys in the military and
um certain groups around the world that
can absolutely do this now a typical
bank robbery you're working within a
certain construct of time and trying to
get a
Vault like that even if you have the
skill set to get into it it would
probably take you as long to get in that
vault as the sentence you forget for
getting into it I have gone into banks
that have safe locks and vaults and time
lock vaults and stuff like that but
there is a bank in Spain that operates
in this way where if certain parts of it
are triggered it will flood the actual
safe
which holds all the gold I'll give it a
10 for entertainment I'm gonna give it a
one
on the
Gil said that anyone would have to go do
that
um
foreign
[Music]
whole body messy
imawa
King Judaism
o
service
terminal s
Wednesday
foreign
I did more than 10 000 burglaries I
wrote everything you can imagine from
museums Banks armored trucks but they
never used any violence my name is
Arthur Brent I'm an art detective and
I'm responsible for recovering 250
million of stolenath We Now work
together in trying to prevent our ties
today we're going to watch out Heist
clips from Hollywood movies tell me
about this one
also from Benin 7th century
Fuller tribe I believe
nah
it was taken by British soldiers in
Benin but it's from wakanda
she's like the director of the museum
and nobody approaches the director
doesn't approach or any one guy art
stolen from Africa is a hot item these
days countries from Africa are demanding
these pieces back from Western museums
because they were stolen during the
colonial era and many of these objects
do have a spiritual meaning for these
countries and in fact I was one of the
first last year who bought such one of
such pieces back an empress Crown stolen
from Ethiopia and we bought it back and
we handed over to the prime minister in
Ethiopia
I'm gonna take a break
it is an inside job you know there is
somebody in it in a
busy house
about what's going to take place it's
very easy to get somebody inside very
easy I did these things you know you
have to find somebody who has problems
you know as debt or something I trace
them where they go where they go out
and then I bump up to him say I'm sorry
you want something to drink but also a
strange thing they come with their open
face he wants to be noticed you you
tracks attention yes too much
good
it's just a taste
the problem with museums is that they
are there for the public they are not
it's not meant to be affording so it's
very hard to really prevent everybody
from from taking something you cannot
put every painting like the Mona Lisa
behind
such as their class
I've never heard of an art theft where
people were killed you know it's uh they
shoot people here like it's you know
it's War it's not like that let's say
you have stolen art uh from a crime like
this you cannot sell it it's too hot
people died you cannot sell it
ridiculous clip
[Music]
I know one Museum who has lasers it's
the country storage Museum in Vienna but
I don't think it's like this you know
you can dance
around these laces I'm like what is this
capoeira stuff are you not this is this
does not exist even if it would exist
like this
not touching any one of these laces is
impossible it's impossible even if you
would have seen them if you would see
him you know without using any spray or
something it's impossible
[Music]
to practice to do this little dance it
will take you about a year
the whole collection is gone what you
see now is going in the air and you'll
be dancing still with your laces I never
studied the alarm for a long time I mean
when you see a building you see how I'm
gonna get in and I see this system and
it will be
yeah uh studied in a minute it's a
system that I can do can hack or not
there must have been a lot of sensors
right I think at least uh 20 or
something is always one or two or three
two and a corner the Techno area I
really doubt if if technology will ever
be that perfect to prevent Earth from
happening because you know there is
always a button you can switch off and
even if they can't find a button you
know they come in with a gun the average
Burger would do would not do this
because it doesn't have a skills or uh
the boss to do it because it looks very
scary they scared of jail
if you can't do the time don't leave a
crime I did crimes I can do the time I
did a lot of time
I give this movie
um
the 10 no kidding a zero
thank you
it looks like it's worth Maybe
30 40 million or something
I don't want to take it from the person
I can see something
that the person is wearing and then
figure out where he lives but not ever
touch anybody but most of these chains
don't even have a lock to open or close
you know and if they have they have
maybe a triple security it doesn't go
over the click one it has to one two
three and then comes off most of these
chains they go over your head if they're
with these kind of stones you know why
do you need a a lock to open or close it
I think this one is very heavy it's
possible to do this you know you have
pickpocket people who can do this they
they take you watch off you don't even
notice any change
the private security they will go in
nobody will stop them because they have
to be with their subject she can't go
outside it's impossible that somebody
will stop these two guys in the
Netherlands is not allowed to have
private guards with guns but outside the
Netherlands it's allowed most of the
security are ex-militated so they have
uh they know a lot about them what they
did before if they're disciplined you
know if they can keep the mouth shut
what they see or noticed
[Music]
yeah I don't even know why is that
coordinated with all kinds of people you
know put the chain into and then it goes
to a kitchen and if you have the change
you run out and I don't know how we have
to get out somebody gets arrested
they don't find the stuff on him on her
you know they already passed it along
otherwise sure uh a suspect then you
have to give it to somebody else I've
been to uh Monaco to check this kind of
necklaces and
it was possible but I didn't know that
half the city of Monaco are cops I
didn't know it's the most secure place
you know that's true I have two cops on
every person or something like that you
won't make it I would say a five thank
you for the fall hello everybody my name
is Brian Stanton I'm a casino executive
in Las Vegas for Station Casinos I have
20 years in the table games business
watching and looking at game Security
today we're going to be looking at
casino Heist movie scenes
I would love to know if a mathematician
out there ever looked at any of those
equations on there and figured out if it
was anything card counting is not some
extravagant trigonometry problem it's
just basic counting second of all you
really can't learn card counting in one
day reading a book The General Public
knowing about it has probably been a
boon for us because people think they
can come out and do it and they really
can't
[Music]
if you're gonna count cards you probably
wouldn't attract that much attention to
yourself you have the character in the
background flipping off the cameras
creating a lot of energy around and
drawing attention to themselves
noticing that they're doing things again
he did split fives which you would never
do even if you were a card counter you
would have to maybe know what the next
three or four cards coming out of the
shoe were to make that make sense he
can't lose
get loose the floor supervisor in The
Pit Boss talking to each other we
wouldn't need to cover our mouths with a
clipboard they're not going to read our
lips it would be hey something's going
on over there we're watching it on
camera let's make a plan for what we're
going to do about it
doing a distraction to escape doesn't
make any sense because they still have
to catch the chips out County cards is
not illegal unless you're using some
device to give yourself an advantage
smart watch or a computer in your shoe
or on your thigh that would make it
cheating a game but keeping track in
your head and knowing how many big cards
versus little cards are you can gain an
advantage and so it's frowned upon is
somebody's card counting in the Las
Vegas casino we simply say hey you're
not welcome to play Blackjack anymore
your action's too good for us this scene
not very realistic in in that regard one
for accuracy of how we do things in a
casino or representing how card counters
would act Ash flows from the tables to
our boxes through the cage and into the
most sacred room in the casino account
room it's not realistic to a modern
Casino as far as how you would enter it
how it's laid out or how the actions are
actually taking place you see the keep
out sign and then they walk in we
wouldn't allow anybody need to walk in
with a briefcase nowadays the workers
that walk in are walking in with clear
purses if at all the count room is the
most secure room in the building there
are procedures in place for who can go
in how they can go in what they can do
where they are there probably in part
because these things did happen when
they were run by individuals or by the
mob versus now publicly traded companies
they're counting money who wants to buy
them and the best part was that upstairs
the board of directors didn't know what
the is going on I mean today I'm
everything looked down the up and up but
you know when you're paying out at the
cage we would count by hand and they did
a good job of how their hand motions
were and how they laid the bills out
every table there's a paddle to the
right of the dealer and they take the
cash and they drop it into a slot and it
goes into what's called a Dropbox and
those are collected daily and they're
double lock secures and security would
come around and remove them take them
into the count room where it's unlocked
and the money is just dropped out onto a
clear table and then the money is
counted and sorted and assigned to that
table the guys inside The Counting Room
all slipped in there to skim The Joint
dry
they do short counts they lose fill
slips they'd even take cash right out of
their drop boxes did it's in a time
period back in the day where you hear
stories about these things going on well
Phil slip is just an order form when a
table game needs more chips throughout
the day as people get up and walk away
and cash out we have to replenish those
chips and you order a fill from the cage
to bring more chips to the table and
that's how you figure out how much a
table wins or loses in a given day and
it was up to this guy right here
standing in front of about two million
dollars to skim the cash off the top
without anybody getting wise the IRS or
anybody the skim was apparently a real
thing that the mob was doing to the
casinos casinos are big business so that
it takes a lot of employees to factor in
the cash that comes through and the
accounting paperwork that goes along
with that so it is a very busy room
there's a lot of people working but not
busy enough that we wouldn't notice
somebody walking in with a briefcase and
walking out with the cash it takes key
access and there's also cameras
everywhere nowadays you can spot these
by watching the way they bet
like this guy he's betting lavender the
chips 500 each with only one little
problem he's always guessed right when
things stand out you take a closer look
at it so they did a great job of how the
dealers are moving how they're paying
how they're putting cards on the tables
to how the supervisors stand in the pit
to even how De Niro's character walked
in and started to observe things I saw
that the dealer was weak but he wasn't
in on it he just wasn't protecting his
hand he was lifting his whole cart way
too high the first thing he noticed was
that the guy always guesses right kind
of bends down to tie his shoes so he can
get a look at what's going on and where
those angles are coming from and figures
out that there's a cheater on the other
side signaling his buddy with a cruise
from casino to casino looking for weak
dealers the way lions look for weekends
using a device to cheat at least in the
state of Nevada is a crime so you don't
see that nearly as often things like
that used to happen as computer
technology took hold if it wasn't for
the device they wouldn't really be doing
anything wrong just taking advantage of
a weak dealer those were the way we used
to check the whole card was for them to
cover it up and look for it nowadays we
have a thing called the peaker device
which is a two-way mirror that they
Slide the cards right into so that
there's no risk of exposing that card
anymore
foreign
I've heard a lot of stories I've never
heard of a cattle prod there are stories
of back rooms without cameras where guys
get roughed up a little bit nowadays we
don't need to do that we have the Nevada
Gaming Control Board we have security
where we would just notify and do
everything through a legal process it's
once they brought that device into play
and we'd notify the gaming commission
say hey we have somebody that we
suspected cheating and we would hand it
right off to them I think the movie was
done incredibly well from a technical
standpoint everything outside of the
cattle prod knocks the clip down to
about a seven and a half
[Music]
I feel like you should have somebody
from the CIA or FBI in here to evaluate
this more than me because it doesn't
pass the smell test for me on how
casinos work or anything that would
happen in a casino I think they say in
the movie it connects three casinos that
in reality are a mile apart there's no
secret bunker anywhere with an elevator
in and then the two security guards just
happen to be facing away from the only
elevator facing a door for no reason
your manager is probably reporting to
you now you have a little over 160
million in your Vault tonight
you may notice we're only packing up
about half that it would depend on how
often deposits are made to the bank or
whatever but we are required to be able
to cover any winners and losers now does
that mean we have to give it to them in
cash no we just write them a check for
it you know modern casinos we've become
increasingly a cashless society and we
have credit markers and bank wire
transfers
yeah in previous Clips we saw where the
count room was and then once the money's
counted it's put into a secure location
you can call it a vault if you want to
but it being this far out of the way
this protected like it's holding the
nuclear codes queue up the tape to the
robbery installed on Tuesday
the images we saw those men robbing us
was a tape
I feel safe to say that nobody has a
vault quite like this one or would we
spend the money to inlay the uh marble
or Terrazzo or whatever that was with
the name of the casino in the vault that
seems like uh we could spend that money
better somewhere else I've worked at
some extravagant opulent places but
that's even a little bit over the top
our directors of security our security
managers all either we're former law
enforcement or know them so they would
know when these guys walked in the
likelihood of an entire team of
criminals pretending to be Las Vegas
Metro or SWAT or whoever and walking out
with money I had a hard time watching
this movie when I watched it the first
time and I'm like wow I really have to
suspend reality to enjoy this a one on
how things in a real Casino look or act
or our run there it is you have got your
wallet but I got your credit cards
laughs